la gloria del Antiguo Egipto tiene un
rostro el de la máscara dorada de
Tutankamón el rey egipcio más conocido
de la historia reinó hace 3000 años pero
no fue hasta hace un siglo que una
expedición liderada por el británico
Howard Carter halló enterrada en el
Valle de los reyes a la orilla del Nilo
la tumba intacta del faraón
fue la única descubierta casi intacta en
el Valle de los reyes es una larga y
bonita historia Cuando a Howard Carter
descubrió la tumba el 4 de noviembre de
1922 encontró 5.398 piezas la mayoría de
ellas eran de oro La tumba en sí era
Modesta pequeña En comparación con el
resto de las tumbas del Valle de los
reyes
la razón de la muerte del joven faraón
que ascendió al Trono A los nueve años y
vivió hasta los 18 intrigó durante
décadas Incluso el rumor de una
maldición pesó sobre su tumba cuando
Egipto inaugura el nuevo gran museo
egipcio en guiza todos los objetos
fúnebres del faraón estarán reunidos en
una misma exposición después de que a lo
largo de un siglo hayan atraído la
admiración de todo el mundo incluso la
de los reyes del presente
por todas partes en películas en
productos en todas partes de hecho desde
que la tumba de Tutankamón fue hallada
hasta hoy Tutankamón es el mejor
embajador de Egipto en el mundo y Egipto
lo sabe y aprecia Este descubrimiento
un descubrimiento bajo colonialismo
británico el protagonismo lo acapararon
los arqueólogos europeos que
invisibilizaron el rol de la población
egipcia en las excavaciones quienes
conocían el terreno y su pasado
ahora Egipto indica su mayor icono un
joven faraón enterrado en una tumba
Modesta donde se detuvo el tiempo y se
abrió una puerta desde la antigüedad a
nuestros días